did you see what i tweeted this morning
yeah
look at the look at the youtube trending
page right now i love what i love
watching white people open gifts
i didn't even photoshop that that's real
all i did was take out the
creator on the rise panel or whatever
but literally the top
six videos i think right now are the
same group of people
can i can i be that can i be that guy
remember when
i told you and i i i told you then i'm
not saying this to be that guy remember
i said
i think youtube is just tripling the
[ __ ] down
was that you yeah sorry guys i'm getting
someone's eyeballs taken out of my
kitchen
oh is that the drilling yeah i know
cartel tick tock is like popping off
right now so i figured you know i know
how to make that content that's easy
oh so that's what you're doing in the
kitchen yeah yeah i'm just outsourcing
it i just got a couple homies here
they're not even mugging hustle dude the
grind never stops man podcasts in the
studio
yeah my kitchen torture yeah you know
they're in
with you know it's a little bit [ __ ]
up because i couldn't find any like
willing like you know latinos to play
the part so i had to hire like some
estonian guys
you know and they they got bandanas
around their face so they're just
they're cosplaying
but yeah we they got pliers and [ __ ]
they're pulling people's teeth out
my tick tock is about to go crazy
smuggle damn dude damn cartel tick tock
i'm trying to think because i was mr
beast is doing like a
year and uh he's doing he's doing his
own youtube rewind
and so he like sent me some questions to
answer and they were all like what's the
best part about
or what was the best part about 2012
what was the best and i'm like
like what was the best thing on youtube
in 20 in 2020 sorry
2012. yeah he's doing a 2012 2012
youtube rewind it's going to be
something
nice yeah yeah and so i was trying to
think i was like what
was the best thing that happened in
content this year i
couldn't think of a single thing but it
was cartel tick tock cars yeah
yeah so i got you know i got people's
teeth being ripped out and [ __ ] that's
actually going to be my next tech talk
yeah i'm going to say yeah and i'm
giving it to you here first
i'm going to be like hey i know cartel
tick tock's going crazy so
i'm just going to hold up a pair of
pliers and then just have someone in the
background like i'm muzzling
no and then just
wide i'm just going to move
just bricks just ran wrapped taped up
pillows and [ __ ] just make it look like
i'm doing them dealing drugs
a body pillow wrapped in [ __ ]
shipping tape hold on i gotta change my
light battery uh-oh
yo speaking of batteries i saw the
funniest tweet it was like
oh you didn't come damn here's some
batteries and it was that 50 cent gift
with him like laughing and like driving
off and
that [ __ ] had me crying here's some
batteries
oh for the vibrator ah nice
i like that so rude yeah just reach into
your nightstand and grab
like just a simple because usually they
only take like one or two depending you
know
yeah just a pack of like a four pack of
duracell and just smacking it on her
stomach
later later it's still in the package
there you go i was like ah what
damn i'm sorry i'm sorry i did that to
you smack
i did what i came here to do literally
yeah yeah i can see
what are we talking about yeah um the
best friends videos yeah
we should make best friends videos man
we should make 17 videos
we should film a vast cringe from four
different angles and upload it on four
different channels
my channel your channels fox the first
one would be
that's cringe whatever the second one
will be best friends cringe
it's cringing to this video and the
third one is
watching best friends cringe to this
[Laughter]
video
i thought that's a good idea i mean well
i wonder what kind of
i don't even wanna um i'm not even gonna
like
watch the video to like wonder what what
gifts they open
i don't know man but it's just all it's
all [ __ ]
um uh like doses of trend
it's just something odd
[Laughter]
it's all it's all just it's all normal
[ __ ] like they're all
they're all opening like gucci wallets
and stuff they're getting each other
gucci
shoes and whatever and then you know one
of them one of them is the one that gets
the weird gifts
like noah beck doesn't really know how
to shop for gifts
he just buys every one trend what is
this
that's like a trend shot i thought we
could all cycle together
james charles on trent
[Laughter]
hi sisters today i don't know anything
about trend dude
hello sister oh sorry trend cough
[Laughter]
he just gets yoked like bretman rock
have you seen that dude lately no
i didn't know that who's that that
[ __ ] is uh man look
look him up man look at brentman rock
before and after
uh
bretman rock yeah you know i don't i
don't want to
oh yeah okay damn buddy just used to be
lean and hyperactive and
it's deadlifting [ __ ] vw bugs man
oh did he la oh he's like a what he
lives man he lives
i mean i don't want to you know is he a
bodybuilder i'm stepping into a world
yeah yeah yeah
well it's like a huge wait did you send
a picture or something
no no i'm going analog today man
okay that's fair yeah i saw some people
on reddit talking [ __ ]
about what they said we're not funny
anymore i said [ __ ] i'll do this
no links it's just a room just to remind
you
we still got it yeah i mean it'd be
better if we were together
it give us a [ __ ] break man this [ __ ]
stop
i'm about to do my billboard yeah what
the [ __ ]
i can't i can't i lost it
that's his [ __ ] stupid person voice
just shut the [ __ ] up
this shit's hard alright podcasting's
hard it's hard dude
it is no man podcasting from home is
i hate doing this [ __ ] virtually stinks
but you realize we're in the epicenter
of the entire world one in
80 people have coveted in la right now
yeah it's pretty it's pretty [ __ ] up
man
one in 80. you go outside you get it
well [ __ ] don't get mad at me from
ohio yeah we just go outside
we can't yeah exactly
the world i don't care about the [ __ ]
world
when you guys going to get back together
just come on just go to the studio man
just get the virus i don't think you
guys realize how many people
we have to just walk past to get to our
studio
yeah and a lot of them are old so if we
have it like it's also uh
you know what i mean oh yeah and cody
and i can just say the translation
system in that building is lost cody and
i could do one passes that building rkd
would be like
six and oh each
potentially killing spree yeah
killings we would come out of covid like
like uh what's
in in cod did they do rankings yeah like
we'd be double prestige
yeah like in in in valorent they do
rankings like we'd be you know diamond
rated players you know what i mean yeah
six 100 yeah oh yeah
you